[Music]
in crypto city news crypto city crypto
city like grip grip grip submitted by
Joe Malian coin counter what a shitty
job
that's an accountant oh I thought he
just like please oh yeah we have
separate bill counters and coin counters
the coin counters collects all the coin
purses from Grandma's and goes like this
and so John Mallia
there's like machine coin counters and
you just smash in front of their face
then they had to buy yeah we just we
would like to keep jobs and it's organic
Akon oh you've been busy with his money
wants to found a real life Wakanda based
around his crypto currency eight coins
why would it mean hmm
I mean he just kind of disappeared like
aliens abducted his ass and then he just
not doing how the charities though a lot
of charities eating my [ __ ] war
hurts it's so interesting because I only
remember Akon for somebody do a lot
somebody threw a water bottle at him
yeah that he picked that [ __ ]
bozo that threw him off the stage oh I
remember that voice yeah well he was
legit a convict before yeah he's a
conduct with the silk is look so
domesticated now yeah finger a rapper
rapper singer he's a singer rapper yeah
sing song rapper yeah so he has been
busy like part said he's been working on
a lot of work I stay in the news because
Bart cares about the world and thinks
about charities where you don't care
about any of those things
situation you're supposed to be my
friend why don't you try
[Laughter]
dude dude that [ __ ] push now what you
have a fire extinguisher put out the
fire babe you need CPR it's okay dear
you got the rest of us we're friends
Sorry Sorry Sorry
my friend you gotta bring it up okay
okay okay my friend
yeah I'm John you ever Joe you have a
[ __ ] new name now dude your name is
Ginsu dude I had to the opportunity just
presented like this I'm not speaking
anymore it's not the right moment for
that Ginsu man Ginsu it was like you
know double dutch it was a double dutch
and like it was my turn a job I had to
do it I [ __ ] was hilarious all right I
understand oh no no no no my best friend
Dave can you please continue yes oh so
it's like that no I didn't say you're
not my friend I just said Bart's my
friend that's all I said
you said I'm Bart yeah
the scientist I am his friend right guys
anyway that's it a con I don't know how
I'm gonna recover from that I'm fine I'm
sorry you I don't know how she's gonna
recover from that well her heart is
broken I know it was just it was just
payback
she got me really like you wasted ten
years of your life hundreds like no you
got me so good no that was so good it's
a meme right now since when was telling
the truth of bad thing the hard way I'm
glad you mentioned that you guys are
even now okay two missions come together
in peace thank you
so he has a charity called a con
lighting Africa and so he has name and
everything doesn't he hey coy Hey
yeah and so that organization is
currently in 25 countries that's
operating in 25 days this guy's terrible
as [ __ ] and the organization the
organization has won awards earned UN
recognition all damn good for him and
they made news last year because they
secured a 1 billion dollar credit line
from China Oh million dollars yeah but
yeah so then now what he wants to do is
create a crypto city with his coin a
coin which that's pretty bill that is
pretty tight that [ __ ] looks like a new
bottle and afro Sheen dude she looks
tight man I know I'm talking about I've
used ice to her I just don't want to
make a coin and then he will come people
could do dump pump and dumps with your
coin that's what's dangerous so a pump
and dump is when a bunch of rich friends
so let's say there's still on board
let's say TIFF has a coin called the
Tippie coin the logo is so small you
can't see all five of us are a part of
tiffey coin and then but we're also very
very rich and then we tell everybody
about tiffey coin right so we tell other
people we tell Wong foo whatever and
then we pump Tippie coin with all of our
money cuz we're all rich right we've got
millions of dollars in that [ __ ]
we raise the price now people jump in
and go oh [ __ ] I'm gonna buy TFE coin
and then everybody starts buying that
[ __ ] and we go ha sucker and we [ __ ]
take all the money out and then a drop
and as its dropping their son their
shares are like oh my god I can't
believe it's dropping so they lose money
and it goes below the value that's when
we buy it again and we go you know what
tiffy coins gonna come back it's gonna
be really cool it's about to rise and
then we pump our money and again and
people see the rise and they start
buying that [ __ ]
so that's a pump and dump and pump and
dump so what's the gain of all these new
people join in and you take their money
and then you you fluctuate you make the
market go up and down and then you make
them freak out and sell their shares
like you buy it at buying at ten bucks
and if you be like oh [ __ ] Scottie
Pippen is buying [ __ ] this [ __ ] then
it goes all I don't know why the oldest
reference ever
a little egg white Scottie Pippen Bravo
basketball it goes all the way back up
to 50 bucks you sell it in the middle or
[ __ ] Scottie Pippen laughs oh [ __ ]
George Washington about their bucks and
they buy it at 10 bucks again hmm
so they make that margin right there at
the pump and dump that's why it's scary
because like let's say you know what
conduct coin gets popular right oh yeah
I like a conical oh yeah I did see the
black pants on it yeah oh that's tight
yeah and all these people come in but
can pump up the point everyone gets
excited and then they buy into the hype
and then BOOM
they take it all out what you gonna do
dan so he's gonna do a city he's gonna
own a city and they're only gonna run on
the eighth coin
yeah well so he's saying that he's
trying to establish a stable currency
alternative throughout Africa he's
saying that a a con crypto City is
currently in development and that there
it has opportunities for crypto
experiences to be painted throughout
this one-of-a-kind cities how they're
selling it so he's trying to do like the
Euro but for Africa like one crypto
currency that could be used everywhere
it seems like yeah that's dope
Gaddafi trying to do that and he got
assassinated oh but it wasn't with
crypto dope he was trying to get off the
US but this is a convict yeah he might
kill the assassinators that's true he's
like I know [ __ ] well Gaddafi was like
a military leader - he was in a [ __ ]
either
now but they still got him they still
got him yep what I would do if I had a
gajillion dollars what charities he at
25 he's 25 no he did 20 open 25
charities 3 countries 25
Sherry's been real busy not gonna love
this god what else did he do huh that's
many a thinks the type of charities that
I like is to help educate the people and
help them get natural [ __ ] like [ __ ]
water and electricity get water you know
that [ __ ] like is like people don't got
[ __ ] run of water man they gotta go
get a sometimes I see videos of these
poor kids with oil [ __ ] bottles and
gas container bottles and they pull
water in that [ __ ] I gotta fill that two
bar he's wasteful what we're talking
about
look at my water nothing but have you
ever seen those though like the the poor
kids they have like it's like first of
all they're in a village there's no cars
and [ __ ] but somehow they have these
like big bottles that are for like drain
all are like some toxic [ __ ] right yeah
and then they're I don't know if they
rinsed it or whatever and they fill that
[ __ ] up with water from the well and
then they [ __ ] use it and I'm like
man I would never do that
I'll never [ __ ] do oil change and
then use that same thing for water
that's sad but also dope at the same
time have you recycling
yeah have you ever seen the some of the
homeless dudes in in downtown LA
they have box duffle bags so what they
do is they take like let's say they find
a abandoned cardboard box and outside it
says like Hoover vacuum or some [ __ ]
vacuum and then they tape their own duct
tape strap on it and they wear it and
that's their luggage so I saw dude I saw
dude with one it was vacuum and there's
his other carry-on it was a microwave
box that's cooler than any duffel bag
I've ever seen
I kinda want to travel like that you
know you don't yes I did no you don't
you always buy the most unnecessary
expensive [ __ ]
what are you talking about the bags
exactly I know but I've reached the top
so now it's like Kanye bought me a [ __ ]
yeah this was gonna hit me up as I yo
you sell your Honda Element away we got
some of crypto city thing others saying
that's in development in Senegal because
the president of Senegal gave Akon two
thousand acres of land and so that's
what he's planning on creating the city
they're saying that it's gonna be a
blend
Martin City Planning design with a blank
canvas for Krypton izing daily human and
business exchanges you did not put your
phone on everything is my laptop it's my
laptop I didn't even though my laptop
could be not well it's a good thing
we're done with this episode
[Music]
[Music]